so we had a story from Business Insider
Bill Gates says political polarization
may bring it all to an end and could
even lead to a Civil War I saw this
headline and I was like wow that's
really interesting thing of him to say
but so what a lot of people have said
that and then I actually scroll down and
read the quote
he says I admit that political
polarization may bring it all to an end
we're going to have a hung election and
a civil war yet he didn't say we might
he he says we are we are going to have a
hung election in a civil war now I
wonder could this be because Bill Gates
reads the bulwark because we we talked
about that last week and I don't know if
you saw the story The bulwark published
an article about how the Civil War could
start
and I think they make an interesting
point that come the midterms you've get
you've got right-wing people and
left-wing people showing up to the polls
duh it's an election and they're
accusing each other of impropriety or
something a fight breaks out someone's
arm someone gets shot there's a viral
video of someone being killed in a
polling place that's what the bulwark
said I don't know for sure but I am I I
do think that if you already have people
who don't trust the election they're of
course going to show up to polling
places I mean what even five people
maybe at each place and then you're
going to get antifa types and leftist
types and they're going to show up as
well and then now what happens well his
comments are very important here because
he said specifically I quote I have no
experience with it I'm not going to put
my money on it because I don't know how
to spend it saying pretty much that it's
guaranteed but then he also went on and
later made the points that it's
polarization and the lack of trust that
is the main problem specifically
pointing at Robert Kennedy as someone
who of course criticized him and and
he's using this this concern which a
large majority of the American people
have a lot of people think there's going
to be a Civil War in this country
according to many polls he's using this
fear in order to Galvanize pressure on
people criticizing him so this is
another aspect to also understand here
with his latest kind of salacious
comments I love this idea like Bill
Gates is sitting in his living room like
watching TV and then he's then he just
comes across this new like a news story
about Robert Kennedy criticizing him and
he goes he said what about me there's
going to be a Civil War in this country
the article also talks about how their
how part of the problem is
misinformation right and we know that
misinformation is a catch-all term that
is used to describe anything that the
left doesn't agree with yep you know
here's my here's my favorite part though
he says quote I have no expertise in
that I'm not going to divert my money to
that because I wouldn't know how to
spend it says the guy who owns more
Farmland than anyone else in the United
States yeah I start to wonder about that
because when he started buying up
Farmland we talked about it right and we
were like creepy why is he doing this
right good investment maybe now he's
like oh yeah and by the way there's
going to be a Civil War and it's like is
is that why you're because here's what I
said when he's like I wouldn't know what
to do I said it's simple like build a
bunker I mean what actually said was get
a get a corporate laundromat and hire
eight German guys to start digging
underneath one of your machines you know
for your you know he's watching Better
Call Saul so yeah I mean he's also
working on a lot of interesting projects
he's introducing a new kind of patented
patented GMO corn into Africa which
allegedly is going to be helping them
deal with hunger and the climate and in
reality he wants to get people off of
meat he wants people to stop using cows
chickens uh pigs in order to fight
climate change and he's doing this with
GMO corn is this corn gonna be the kind
that has no seeds you know how there was
like Monsanto Monsanto seeds that yeah
that did that specifically so farmers
had to keep buying it from them farmers
were sued even for cross-pollination
exactly previously before it's still
unknown the details of what's Happening
Here but Bill Gates was one of the major
backers of Monsanto which introduced
corn which is heavily subsidized and
creates high fructose corn syrup which
is banned in many places around the
world so wait wait wait they produced
corn that made no seeds
um they produced a number of of
agricultural products that produced no
seeds so the farmer always had to buy
Santa would be dependent and I know
there's like seedless watermelon I'm
just imagining I'm wondering about how
corn seedless corn would work since all
corn is seeds right so I think as I said
yeah
yeah well I mean it's it's the it's
sterilized yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's
like regrow yeah yeah so but I'm
wondering I mean like uh seedless fruits
things like that we have seedless grapes
I'm just wondering like it's like I'm
imagining a dystopian future where
people find seats and they're like we're
safe and they plant them and they get
one crop and then there's no
reproduction and there's nothing yeah
exactly and it's over yeah that's why
they have uh they have those seed
vaults in the Arctic right yeah it's in
uh was that Norway or is it I think it's
Norway is it Norway savalabarden yeah
the seed Vault where they store all
those seeds because I guess uh we don't
want to die yeah we don't want to die I
think it's a good idea humans are grown
quite fond of living yes
but but as he's trying to push for
climate change telling people not to eat
uh real meat he also has 100 patents on
synthetic uh Meats on synthetic cheeses
he also has a lot of intellectual
property and and he's he he literally
just came out a couple months ago and
said rich countries need to switch to
completely synthetic beef which of
course would greatly benefit him more
than anyone else so so we have to start
thinking about why he made these
comments now about Civil War and what's
the greater benefit to him as of course
it's also important to note here that he
is a man that has finance and funneled
hundreds of millions of dollars into the
corporate media that literally acts like
his PR marketing team that regurgitates
all of his larger business proposals and
sells it to the American and into
national public the guardian of the BBC
MSNBC many organizations are directly
financed by Bill Gates and this is why
you can't trust any legitimate news
coverage as well as also the fact
Checkers that of course attack any
criticism of him which is absolutely uh
dystopian and ridiculous to live in such
a world of way where he can't even
criticize this billionaire that is best
friends with Jeffrey Epstein I just
say they don't think Civil War is
possible and stuff and I'm just like
more and more people are are each
other's throughouts more and more people
are accusing each other of being evil it
doesn't matter if you're right or
they're right you know we think we're
right I think we have evidence to back
it up we don't we don't fall for the
hoaxes Like Jesse Smith or the Covington
kids or the Duke best the Duke
volleyball thing Duke volleyball the
lacrosse thing no the volleyball thing
oh yes but then there was the young
woman who said that she was the
volleyball player and she was out at BYU
and there was a racial slur there was a
racial slur and that people were calling
her racial slurs the whole time and
after an investigation it turned out
nobody else had heard it at all right so
so no one had said but the corporate
media ran with it like it was a real
story even though it was a public event
in front of other people and I remember
looking at that story when it came out
and we were like uh we're gonna hold on
this because I bet this is a hoax and
then sure enough it was so this is the
point I mean we sit here we read the
news we're like okay these things are
probably fake oh here's another story
that's probably fake we're gonna wait
for evidence
the other side is just like must be true
let's roll around with it it doesn't
matter who actually is right though
truth is irrelevant as much as I think
truth matters for us in terms of will a
Civil War happen the truth is
meaningless and it's exemplified very
simply if you go to one of these people
and say
um here's the truth they go don't care
you know that people are yes that does
happen that makes it all the more
important for us to hold on to reality
and hold on to the truth I agree to
stand on it you have to stand on the
truth that for for existence and reality
the truth matters what I'm saying is in
terms of will there be a civil war it
doesn't matter if you hold the truth or
they hold the truth because they are
zealots who will Who will believe
whatever is placed in front of them so
you can go to them as an outsider Like
Larry I think it was Larry Elder
pointing this out and show them here is
the transcript from the New York Times
of trump saying condemn the white
supremacist and they go I don't care I
don't want to hear it right because they
don't think that it matches what they
believe already I mean a civil war
though like you know you and I were
talking about this before we aired and
the people who are like oh I walk
outside and nobody's angry at each other
there's no fighting in the street a
civil war wouldn't be like fighting in
the street people would arm up go to
their separate camps you know like go to
their separate areas or whatever well no
no sort of we have this tweet here from
Scott Adams and he says there won't be a
Civil War in the United States not even
close there is no appetite for it
outside Twitter imagination one person
said your source and his response was
walking outside wasn't he earlier just
saying that people are going to be shot
in the streets he was saying Republicans
will be hunted and then like we did see
that happen on a couple occasions so I
don't know why he's changing his mind
the other thing though is what I
responded to him was
about walking outside in Portland La
Chicago or New York with a trump shirt
on but I agree Scott Adams uh may be
right it could just be a slow revolution
of authoritarian Powers because the
right doesn't want to fight
but here's the point I made
it's imagine it's eight it's January
1861. and a guy in Atlanta walks out of
his house and he's fuming he's like oh I
just read the paper and I hate those
Yankees oh and then he walks up to his
neighbor and punches his Southern
neighbor in the face why would he do
that his neighbor agrees with him of
course you can walk outside and no one's
fighting like people in New York agreed
with each other they were cheering on
the the uh what was it it was the the
dude it was a southern dude who caned a
northern guy right I think it was the
canine I remember their names but like
one side was cheering it on one side was
condemning it so yeah in the South you
walked outside and everyone was like it
was bad that happened and then people in
the north are like it was good that
happened or I think it's inverted the
point is yeah you surprised that you
walked outside in like 80 percent
Democrat New York and nobody's fighting
each other okay well put on a put on a
Maga hat like Blair white didn't walk
around L.A and see how long it takes
until they attack you because they did
Blair got attacked this was years ago so
yeah
you can get attacked I'm not saying
that's proof Civil War is going to
happen I think we look at what the FBI
is doing and we're like oh I mean
certainly the FBI going after they just
rated the home of a pro-life activist
right that was crazy absolutely insane
over over like because they're like it's
a
um the face act because you assaulted
somebody who was working at an abortion
clinic even though the charges were
dismissed by a court right right and
this is like what years later or
something right one year so you know
when I see the FBI weaponize and going
after run-of-the-mill conservatives just
like this is like a regular person this
is not like a politician my immediate
instinct is instinct is Civil War but my
point here is that no no Scott might be
right you know conservatives on the
right might just you know get on their
knees and say you know I'm so sorry
please I don't want to fight well we
have been doing that for a while that's
been going on look I understand about
the thing about saying that it's all
just happening on Twitter though is
Twitter is our Collective imagination
you know like it it's debatable but you
know I think it's there as part of what
we are imagining and what we believe and
it's a it's a where we're exploring
ideas in real time we're certainly not
doing that in any other aspect of our
society that's not happening in books
that's not happening in movies or TV or
on the news we're exploring ideas in
real time and Twitter has a direct
impact on how Democrats are spending
money yeah they see the the tweets the
Bots and everything and they say this is
what we should promote and then all of a
sudden the Democrats are advocating for
child's child sex changes right so like
and then saying that they're not and
then saying actually they are good you
know the New York Times was defending
them today exactly the New York Times
put out an article saying yeah actually
these things do happen right yeah
because they have to do it they said
they said it does happen and this doctor
who finds most of her clients on Tick
Tock is doing great things with
marketing on social media meanwhile they
were censoring and blacklisting and
destroying people's lives because they
were saying that a few weeks ago they
were saying no this is not true they're
literally a few weeks ago yes like two
weeks ago citing violence and then
there's like oh no no it's good no
hospitals are chopping off girls boobs
when they're 14. oh wait it's good that
they are they are right it's good I
think when it comes to like will there
won't there be some sort of civil
conflict that escalates it's basically a
morale question of morale if people get
broken morally and then they they'll
just resort to The Last Resort which is
always violence so and people in America
are generally pretty high morale because
we have it awesome here like fresh water
good food warm buildings
um transportation if you destruct I
think if we didn't have that stuff it
would be way easier to spiral into Decay
mentally
um and then what other choice do you
have it is sort of a luxurious culture I
was talking to a friend of mine from
Morocco the other day and we were like
yes it's unbelievable the Bounty at the
grocery stores you know that we can get
anywhere that everything is you know we
have the fresh water all of these things
this is a story I like to tell about
when I was in Brazil that many people
listen I've probably heard but for those
that haven't I was at a favela where
they couldn't flush their toilet and it
was just all of the family's waste
piling up because they needed rain so
they had no water and I was like you
have a bathroom like right there and I'm
like I ain't going anywhere near that
thing so they have it rough and then the
the mother asks something in Portuguese
and then you know my friend translated
and he says she's asking you why the
rich people are protesting in America
and then I was like what do you mean and
he asked her and she says blah blah blah
he goes Occupy Wall Street you know like
the people they're protesting and I went
it's not the rich people protesting it's
like young people college kids like
Working Class People they're upset
because the corporations were getting
bailouts from the government the
government was giving them money and the
banks so basically they feel like
they're not getting their fair share and
then he tells her and then she laughs
and she says she says something and he
goes she said all Americans are rich
pretty much and I was like I would agree
with that to a certain extent from her
perspective she's like these people have
like clean running water and in like
their lowliest of Apartments like even
the bad Apartments have clean running
water I mean yes we have we have poverty
and we all have all of that but we do
have a very high standard of living
across the board I think and we've done
great things to get rid of child poverty
I think that's true yeah every day we
still I am I mean this is just when I
think about like will there won't there
I feel very much like we are and maybe
not in control but influencing it
because it's like a morale system well
and one thing that had such a huge
impact on on that obviously is fossil
fuel
you know fossil fuel was responsible for
uh oh yeah decreasing poverty globally
for decreasing poverty in the U.S and
creating seven billion people yes when
you look at the the Advent of the
petroleum industry human population goes
straight to the train and that's what we
have I mean the isn't the Petro dollar
what we really have to thank for our
wealth too so I have to wonder when you
get someone like Bill Gates who's like
climate change over and over again when
they want to get rid of fossil fuels it
sounds like what they're really saying
is like yo we use too much energy too
quick and now there's too much going on
we help too many people there's too much
activity there's too much Freedom
there's too much Prosperity we must have
it all for ourselves and this kind of
egomaniac kind of idea like I mean look
most likely the planet is suffering but
why should I give up it's suffering
because of them and what they're doing
to the
environments they live in the Mansions
they they boat around in the little
Yachts as of course they go to China
exploit slave labor and all the
non-regulations there that they called
for and put up and set up their Bill
Gates made literally advises the Chinese
government what else do you need to know
about what he's really behind and what
he's really doing he complimented the
Chinese government said they did a good
job with covid okay thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there